le président du parti progressiste
martiniquais est avec nos lendemain de
la rentrée politique de son mouvement
bonjour serge chimie bonjour le mot
d'ordre distiller hier soir auprès des
sympathisants la résistance face
dites-vous aux poisons terrible du
populisme de l'équipe d'alfred marie
jeanne et de claude lise serge letchimy
oui parce que le peuple s'est exprimé
ses ses leaders politiques en eu le
temps de s'installer de s'organiser
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui à la
fois beaucoup de démagogie beaucoup de
mensonges
on l'a vu sur la question du déficit pas
de déficit
et deuxièmement le pays ne bouge pas ne
bouge plus et nous avons de vrais
dangers de récession et pour nous il
faut s'organiser pour résister sans
faire des critiques simpliste il faut
absolument s'organiser et se structurer
alors ce déficit ce fameux déficit ou
cet excédent ce fameux excédent au delà
du chiffre de la méthode pour le trouver
du symbole qu'on veut en faire alfred
marie-jeanne et vous serge letchimy ne
pensais pas qu'à se chient que ce
chiffre n'a finalement nous sommes
représentent rien dans ce budget comme
ceux d'une structure comme la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
ont parlé de quelques chiffres de ce
déficit même de 80 et quelques millions
ou d'un accident de c'est vous ne
trouvez pas qu'on il ya deux éléments il
ya un élément de bonne gestion pas pour
se disputent pour bruit non quelques
temps il y à un élève est une question
de bonne gestion certainement vous avez
l'obligation de gérer une collectivité
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
d'optimisation économique mais en même
temps de terminer que des résultats
acceptables si vous avez des déficits de
80 200 millions d'euros vous mettez en
difficulté le pays et monsieur marie
jeanne a fait quoi la population qu'il y
avait un déficit abyssal rapatrie de les
aliments d'anti moi dis moi oui je sais
pas moi qui l'étreignait donc il y à des
juges financiers
un championnat des comptes qui ont fait
le boulot et qui constatent qu'ils
avaient pas du tout déficit n'y avait
pas de 80 millions de déficit y'a pas de
23 millions de déficit il y avait
il ya un excédent c'est un résultat
extrêmement important pour nous il ya
l'indépendance des juges qui fait
absolument saluer parce que nous n'avons
aucun privilège avec ses juges
je considère que il faut absolument que
on arrête ce genre de choses et qu'on
essaie d'éviter de cacher ses propres
carences uns dénonçant des choses qui
n'existent pas alors vrai parlait hier
d'une volonté de détruire de la part de
l'équipe majoritaire à l'assemblée de
martinique au conseil exécutif une
volonté de détruire qui serge et chimie
le parti progressiste martiniquais même
la population martiniquaise si on en
croit ce que vous souhaitez d'hier soir
à traînel la volonté de destruction et
est réel lorsqu on s'acharne à vouloir
éliminer quelqu'un en invente un déficit
en état extrêmement virulent violence
attaquant personnellement cette personne
et en découvrant la suite mais qui a pas
de déficit qui a pas de trafic qui a
absolument rien qui a un pays où on a
investi énormément on a des résultats
très importants
c'est pour mieux cacher ses propres
carences c'est ça la tactique est
aujourd'hui on constate quoique là
martine gay vesti plus la martinique ne
crée plus d'activités de la martinique
étant pratiquement un train de hadari 20
chiffres hier soir une augmentation de
0,4 pour cent du produit intérieur brut
pour la martinique alors que guadeloupe
et guyane ce serait beaucoup plus de 8,9
oui absolument nous avons actuellement
une croissance extrêmement faible on a
actuellement une activité extrêmement
molle pour les entreprises
nous avons des fonds européens qui sont
sympas ça peut être la cause d'une seule
personne c'est forcément tous ceux qui
étaient aux commandes en cours de la
dernière année et des deux dernières
années va peut-être que je pense qu'il
ya peut-être des responsabilités
partageable mais dans cette circonstance
non parce que lorsqu'on arrive aux
investissements en martinique
lorsqu'on à démanteler l'ensemble de
l'organisation notamment sur la gestion
des fonds européens qu'est ce qu'on a
actuellement et bien sûr les fonds
européens au risque d'avoir des
dégagement d'office au risque d'avoir
aidé des fonds européens non utilisées
qui reparle belle aventure a dit qu'il
n'en sera rien monsieur mégane avant tu
as l'habitude de se trahir lui
même par ses propos il y est bien
entendu qui le dira mais ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons des
risques extrêmement pendant je souhaite
pas ça pour le pays je dis simplement
que nous arrivons enfin avant la fin de
l'année et quand vous entendez des
acteurs économiques on est assez
perturbé sur le niveau de consommation
des fonds européens l'euro môme a
fondamentalement besoin lorsque vous
parlez de l'économie martinique
martiniquaise est ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même le droit à la
nouvelle équipe dirigeante
le temps de regarder comment les choses
se passent le temps de prendre de
s'installer tout simplement oui
certainement mais dans une nouvelle
collectivité vous mêmes le saviez que ce
n'aurait pas été facile même pour vous
si vous aviez gagné les élections
désendettement nous sommes extrêmement
tolérant avec la nouvelle équipe parce
que nous avons très rapidement indiqué
qu'ils frappent alors un petit peu de
temps d'autant plus qu'ils avaient
décollé deux collectivités a rassemblé
c'est pas très évident mais le niveau de
carence aujourd'hui est extrêmement
alarmant est grave je pense que
l'enseigné risque dans notre cas dans
une récession alfred marie-jeanne assez
forte si jamais on repart pas son
investissement alfred marie-jeanne accra
même dénoncé le manque de préparation de
cette nouvelle collectivité qui arrivait
la collectivité était extrêmement bien
préparé il a démantelé tout il a
démantelé le groupement d'intérêt public
pour les fonds européens ce qui conduit
à la catastrophe que nous avons
aujourd'hui l'arrêté pratiquement tous
les chantiers bel exemple du lycée est
extrêmement clair le lycée de transit je
parle pratiquement tout le chili hôtes
et csp est bloqué ça n'avance pas du
tout aussi bloquée mais la martinique
est bloquée et tout le monde voit que la
martinique n'avance plus inventifs et
totalement ralenti pratiquement planté
je souhaite vraiment que il des plantes
la martinique et repartent en
investissement mais le risque est énorme
le risque est extrêmement important j'ai
très peur d'une récession qui pourrait
conduire à des perturbations graves
alors c'est pour cela que vous appelez
donc votre parti le ppm le ciel au siège
de traînel hier soir vous avez appelé à
cette résistance qui va s'organiser
comment pour vous pour vous ces rejets
chimiques pour les différents balisiers
de martinique d'abord et nous avons
réussi
premier défi c'est notre congrès avec
une nouvelle équipe à la tête et d'une
image art comme nouveau comité national
bien sûr nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants pour tous où tout ce qui se
passe en martinique ça va pas le refaire
les élections tout le temps et la
défaite digérée vous êtes en ordre de
marche nous avons perdu le peu peut pas
faire un choix je crois qu'il apparaît
assez incohérent puno ce mariage
burlesque ah bon mais c'est le peuple
qui a fait son choix il faut respecter
ce choix nous sommes dans une situation
extrêmement difficile le la martinique
est actuellement la région qui est très
en retard par rapport à la guadeloupe et
la guyane qui dans une vraie dynamique
économique et ne voyons pas de
perspective donc il faut absolument que
le parti devienne redevienne parti de
résistance structurants ses idées
définissant ses perspectives essayant de
préparer pour protéger la légine tracy
vous dites aussi il faut protéger la
démocratie parce qu'on a été en danger
est bon voici vous exprimer les autres
s'expriment vous avez pas ce qu'ils vont
devenir
et vu comment fonctionnent les plénières
où l'opposition n'a pas droit à la
parole hué par des gens qui sont dans
les étages la démocratie c'est pas
seulement ce qui se dira de l'assemblée
martinique je ne sais pas si vous
concevez cela comme ça mais c'est
extrêmement grave et dont je suis se
passe pendant qu'il faut absolument que
les choses se rétablissent qu'on garde
notre sang froid le fonctionnement
actuel de l'institution
c'était m est incroyable ise et confiné
dans un rôle de passeur de parole et
affectueux verdict si vous êtes vous
sûrs sereine je sais pas moi c'est lui
qui le dit c'est lui qui vous l'a dit
maintenant c'est monsieur mal jeune qui
dit clairement que i messieurs n'est pas
dubaï a fait qu'à passer la parole donc
et il a clairement dit à chaque de
rachat sur place c'est vraiment qui le
dit je vous le dis et deuxièmement on a
bien vu que le fonctionnement
démocratique de l'institution se fait
par l'assemblée doit être relativement
autonomes sinon très autonome par
rapport à l'exécutif
aujourd'hui rien ne se passe dans cette
institution n'a pas de choses nouvelles
a pas surfer sous quelques chantiers
commencés par notre équipe
je souhaite vraiment que la martinique
prennent aux vraies balles avancer je ne
dis pas ça pour critiquer critiquer mais
je serai demain qu'on sorte de la
torpeur et qu'il hésite
nouvelle et qui se structure qui
s'organise même si c'est ce n'est pas
votre équipe qui est aux commandes à
l'assemblée de martinique et de france
exécutif il ya des choses que vous
observez aujourd'hui qu'il aurait fallu
améliorer amendé concernant le
fonctionnement de cette nouvelle
connectivité d'abord redonner à
l'assemblée ses vraies capacités
démocratiques de fonctionnement il faut
absolument que le président et son
équipe
je parle de claude lise puisse être très
autonome très structuré et ne soit pas
une simple dessous fils du président
d'exécutif la deuxième chose je pense
qu'il fait véritablement présenté au
martinique un vrai plan vous savez un
après notre élection nous avions déjà un
plan d'urgence de relance qui a permis
de stabiliser le pays d'investir
énormément et aujourd'hui on en voit
rien à part les chantiers qu'on nous
avons commencé ce sont les seuls
chantiers y a aucune idée nouvelle
il ya simplement et des gens qui
recherchent un petit peu leur posture et
qui sait de détruire tout ce qu' on a
commencé auparavant on arrêtait le
chantier on a tout arrêté
alors si on a à la fois on arrête les
chantiers qui sont entamées et puis on
n'a pas de nouvelles perspectives
on ne peut surfer que ce le lycée
schoelcher qu'on nous avons déjà
commencé les gens donnent l'impression
qu'ils ont commencé dès hier que nous
avions déjà commencé les bâtiments des
résidences pour eux et pour les
professeurs sont terminées et premier à
démolition a été fait ça a été le
gymnase le permis était obtenue sur
notre permis qui est utilisée de
démolition de constructions
c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'on puisse
utiliser ce que nous avons fait or dix
autres on est vraiment 10 secondes serge
letchimy les législatives de juin
prochain
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle va
se mettre en ordre de marche quand
est-ce à nous sommes dépendants de
marche
nous avons une très grande réunion que
nous organisons d'ici trois semaines et
ensuite on va s'organiser pour prendre
une décision avant le 15 décembre
très bien merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin ça je suis président
du parti pour east martinique